on arrive au même moment que les joueurs
c'est la good news gens voient leur aide
pour que vous soyez basculer
automatiquement
allez ça va partir de l'autre côté ça a
dû fonctionner je vais ajouter
l'échiquier on arrive pile à l'heure
l'échiquier qui va chier qui est là il
ya un pion des quatre sais pas trop
pourquoi ça doit être une une erreur de
retransmission parce que je vois pas de
pièces sur l'échiquier
donc là il ya un pion
est parti en d4 je sais pas si c'est le
si c'est juste
ben ouais je crois qu'il ya un bug là
les amis dit que ces 4 j'ai envie de
vous faire confiance je la camair en
plus petit que vous donc j'ai plus de
j'ai un peu de mal à a jugé bon ça peut
pas être des 4,5 ça va être carte cinq
cavaliers 3 kgs c6 ça va rejouer une
espagnole et ça a joué le cavalier fils
donc une berlinoise et des trois anti
berlinoise ce que j'ai fait ici qu'est
ce que tu attends un tour en 2 victoires
en toi féminins n'ont pas spécialement
si je suis pas lui dire je lui dirai
mais des trois des six sais je suis pas
trop le tourin féminin en vrai je
regarde pas trop les parties je
regardais parti à défier avec attention
quand elle joue dans des tournois mixtes
mais à mai mais papa dans l'es3 fémur et
donc ils jouent ces trois donc anti
berlinois ça ressemble un petit peu à
des italiennes dans l'esprit parce que
la structure va être une structure de
type italienne on se reçoit et que 4,5
et des six detroit et les blancs qui
essayent de pousser des 4 et en plus le
fou il peut repartir vers 1 4 puis
versez 2 et donc ça peut ya pas mal
italienne où le fou il repart entre
detroit et on sait de aussi il peut
aussi repartir vers b3 il peut repartir
vers c4 et ya même des cas de figure où
comme dans l'italienne a prêté 4 rock
tour e1 le four parents en f1 se se
mettre sur cette case de départ qui soit
une bonne case pour les fous et donc ça
ressemble dans le dans la stratégie dans
le jeu stratégique de deux milieux de
jeu plus à une italienne qu'une espagnol
en réalité
donc après ces trois minutes réfléchit
donc c'est lui qui est venu avec une
surprise j'ai envie de dire en premier à
magnus puisqu'il a joué la berlinoise et
on s'attendait plutôt à ce qu'ils
retournent dans ce qu'il a fait hier et
dans ce qu'il a fait dans le dans le
toit c'est à dire des espagnols
classique avec à 6,1 après ses 3 et
encore masse de théorie avait plusieurs
coups ici froid qui a g6 pour mettre le
fond g7 et rockets ont joué avec fu 17
pour temporiser il ya à 6 e 6 x 4 et l'a
de nouveau j'ai six possibles ce qui va
leur disposition un million de fois déjà
dans le tchat
oh oui probablement mais tu essayes de
comprendre quelles sont les idées de
l'adversaire donc là il est reparti sur
g6 rock foo g7 évidemment il connaît un
magnus mais on essaye de faire les bons
choix et de jouer les les bonnes les
bonnes variantes pour pour la partie en
cours à ce niveau là l'impact des
ouvertures est vraiment énorme et il a
joué tour je crois qu'il va y avoir rock
et l'idée c'est que fo angers 7 il est
vraiment bien placé si vous avez regardé
la vidéo de ce matin qu'on a fait avec
mathieu on vous a expliqué que c'était
souvent un bon set-up d'avoir les deux
fois en sciant kétou pour jouer contre
contre la poussée au centre alors les
blancs pourraient aussi pousser mais les
fous serait vraiment puissant pour pour
contre attaquer ce centre est ici après
rock rock les non blancs ont joué h3 je
crois alors l'idée de h3c quand on fait
des cats on en parle aussi dans la vidéo
de ce matin il peut y avoir des
histoires avec soient prises prise sous
g4 où j'ai quatre direct qui vient
mettre la pression sur le centre qui dès
2 h 3 c'est un peu un coup de
temporisation qui empêche foulée 4 qui
sort un peu de cette idée
à noter que
sur bay 5 du coup là on aura fait un
chemin un peu long en jouant foulée cinq
fois à 4,9 à ramener le fou directement
ces deux et se fout il est bien placé
puisqu'il protège le point 4 et donc sur
un coup comme tours 8 des cas puis on
prend plus on prend cavaliers prend
pourrait reprendre en quatre après on
peut aussi parfois jeu avec fougue les
trois ans dix ans qu'on a dû cavaler g5
dans leur âge et que dans ce genre de
position on peut avoir du fou des cinq
s'associe une tactique thématiques à
connaître qui vient taper sur tout la
diagonale mais je pense sur b 5e c'est
plutôt poussé de 1re nettement après fou
b3 peut aussi être une option tout cas
magnus qui réfléchit bouddha j'ai envie
de dire étonnamment bien préparé il est
vraiment venu avec d'autres armes dans
ce tournoi et il pourrait il pourra l'en
finale est allé faire et aller faire mal
aux candidats l'année prochaine le
joueur polonais est vraiment très fort
un set dans ce tournoi dans cette coupe
du monde
mais le champion du monde une nouvelle
fois pas très à l'aise
est ce étonnant il a joué car les bébés
8h15 ces poursuites comme dans une
breyer est allé remettre du b 5 c 5 fu
bessette qui a validé s'être replacé les
pièces différemment ça libère le pion
c'est le cavalier c6 a fait le taf
en fait après cavaliers f3 il a fait le
taf pour protéger le pion aux cinq ans
jouant cavalier c6 et maintenant on le
remet sur sa case de départ pour libérer
le pion c est jouer le centre alors est
ce que c'est bon dans cette position ça
c'est une autre question alors qu'on
voit duda en grand plan chemise blanche
est fatigué changer de chemise entre les
parties moi j'aurais aimé lui met un des
quatre continue-t-il participer l'équipe
slipstream ah non ils ont une équipe
polonaise maintenant je pense qu'il va
avec le pion des 4 il a joué car est
libre
des deux c'est un coup de préparation
c'est un coup de préparation et de
développement
donc on peut jouer avec ses 5 pouces et
2 b5 et c5 est retourné dans des
positions d'espagnol assez marrant parce
que c'est enfin j'espère vraiment que
vous avez regardé la vidéo de ce matin
ça ça vous aidera à mieux comprendre les
enjeux de la position l'avantagent qui
avait 8 ans ont des cinq vins b5 tête
qui va pas de jouer en fait un tête qui
va laisser le fond à 4 le plus longtemps
possible que ce fonds 1 4 est ce qu'il
est vraiment bien placé c'est une
question
denquin
7 peut-être qu'il va jouer sous ses deux
de tout fan de toutes manières rudes à
ce que car il ya vingt cavaliers e3 ici
tu joues plus la cad tu voues par la
case f5 qui a fait repousser deux mais
le truc c'est que b5 tu vas peut-être de
voir le jour et dans tous les cas et là
on aura peut-être à quatre foulées sets
et un peu comme on l'a vu dans les
parties d'hier après b si je trouve que
c'est un peu mou
sur ces 5 des quatre je pense à sur ces
5 et aussi du cas ici quatre cavaliers 3
passes et 4 gagne un temps sur le pion
des six j'aime bien la position des
blancs préoccupe un spécialiste de
l'espagnol ma force de commenter des
partis et d'en voir
position est compliqué je sais que le
sous-estiment un peu le 16/07 ap avec
fougue et cette donc du coup je peux
avoir un biais cognitifs qui donne un
avantage blanc qui n'existe pas mais bon
toujours eu quand des quatre c4 arrive à
duda qui fait forte impression un
bouddha qui continue à faire forte
impression
c'est vrai que dans ce tournoi si les 6
or gris chucky et et carole scène ce
sera pas rien quand même
ce n'étaient pas des adversaires faciles
comment va jouer
magnus ici je pense qu'il va quand même
henri c5 et c4 dame ses sept quarts l'e3
et des quatre qui partira il a joué b5
ouais donc il veut retrouver le set up
avec fougue et 7 je me demande si on va
pas se retrouver dans une transposition
finalement est-ce qu'on peut pas
transposer dans une espagnole
il doit y avoir un détail après comme je
suis pas spécialiste cette ouverture
alors tout ça est déjà aux candidats
même si le père n'ont vu qu'ils
joueraient feydeau cfa serre que
fedoseyev en fait c'est un penalty the
rings coco l'asticot c'est pas un
feydeau cf faut aller le chercher le mec
a quand même 27 20
il a joué bathing qu est ce qu on va se
retrouver avec du cavaliere fou nos
cavaliers d'être cavaliers de tresses je
pense pas et des cats y aura foule
bessette sûrement le pion des deux pions
des 3/4 sont assez cool un pur pour
éteindre le four bessette et le fou g7
et un par le pion aux 5 et c'est vrai
que dès qu'on joue des quatre ont fait
jouer les deux fous quoi après tu par le
plan avec des quatre des cinq aussi mais
il faudra faire gaffe de passe prendre
ces six mois parce que tu peux jouer des
quatre pour des cinq mondes car elle est
déjà venue en 17 tu gagnes plus de temps
qu'il a fait à quatre fous bessette
alors est ce que il a le plan b 4 four
b3 et b4 par la suite dans le règne en
grèce il ya quatre décades probablement
à ben voila je commence à apprendre des
leçons du maître cornetto à force
d'analysé fréquemment chez piper rien
aux espagnols et la dette avec le nom d'
analyse que j'ai dû faire avec
avec mathieu ou fab je commence à sentir
les coups et du coup un coup comme des
cas peut bien plus à l'idée qu'avant et
il peut essayer peut-être de revenir en
b3 jeu la casse des cinq ou même jouer
avec des 4
quand je disais poussée des 4 c'est un
peu à double tranchant d'un côté on
prend le centre mais d'un autre côté on
s'expose aux fous alors que tant qu'on
est comme ça les fous sont un peu bête
je suis sûr qu'il ya eu des
transpositions dans des espagnols
classique
mathieu va pouvoir confirmer mais je
suis sûr qu'il ya des transpositions à
la vente dreyer
bon on va voir pour le moment c'est une
partie sympa et duda duda qui a l'air
confiant il n'a pas l'air trop stressé
parce que c'est pour lui il ya quand
même un gros enjeu mais il a l'air bien
dans son truc
jean-christophe et pour aller se
qualifier aux candidats par un membre
hertz avec des catés fouet cette info
met à ce plan de faire tourner vite fait
fille jessie sous les 7e et ça peut pas
transposer et trop de temps perdu mais
c'est quand même cette idée des bruyères
québec qui a 17
ça pue quand même transposer dans des
trucs avec a6b cinq de base n'ont pas
vraiment ça retombe dans les structures
tout a très relax après tout il est
contre le meilleur joueur de tous les
temps qu'at-il à perdre bas beaucoup une
demi finale je pense pas mystère pessoa
que les joueurs bon sens mal joué contre
le meilleur joueur de tous les temps en
gros je pense qu'il se dit je joue
contre un mec lambda je vais le défoncer
les joueurs de haut niveau ils sont pas
en mode
le mec est le meilleur joueur de tous
les temps je vais le pet ont quoi
normalement ils sont plus en mode
si je veux si je vais être champion du
monde un jour jouer à le battre pourquoi
pas commencer aujourd'hui sa tranche est
en espagne à 4 x 6 x 4 et des trois des
six ok on est d'accord qu'on appelle
tous les plans avec cavaliers ce v8 qui
a aidé cette des plans breyer nom
mathieu c'est moi qui ai une fausse
appellation et il joue ses 5
ok c'est 5,5 ou responsables parce que
ça fout le bordel
première question c'est quand même si on
prend alors s'y prend 2 d
vous dire ça m'a pas l'air bon mais en
fait j'en sais rien
j'aurais dit non car brière pour moi
c'est juste une lente mais je suis pas
du tout spécialiste ok moi j'aurais
donné l'idée qu'il y avait but qui avait
17 une idée breyer mais bon tu vois je
suis pas spécialiste non plus haut
parlantes renom spécialiste des noms
d'ouverture avec mathieu st visuellement
j'aime bien j'ai pas ça enlève un peu de
protection a eu cinq et il ya quand même
le plan de revenir rapidement vers des
cinq qui me plaît je pense que c'est
plutôt sur pions prend cavaliers prendre
le coup puisque le cavalier peut être
gênant il tape detroit il tape il tape
4s compass est sûre à bab sur dame tout
reprendre satisfait dame prend il retape
sur e4 mettait je fais tourbe est un fou
quelque part pour protéger et d4 est ce
que ça c'est possible
complexe car elle
4 qui peut aller chercher de pioncer 3
ouais nan c'est hyper compliqué est-ce
qu'on peut essayer de jouer cette finale
peut-être parce que le foin à 3 il est
hyper fort ils tapent sur des six 6
blocs le pion et les noirs ou un
problème avec leurs ailes roi et le plan
avec f5 va être trop long à venir
il ya du cavalier c4 qui arrive et ça a
l'air d'être plutôt gênant ouais c'est
hyper compliqué un lacet réellement
hyper compliqué après b prend ses 5
c'est une idée mais on peut aussi jouer
on peut talent toujours tu as joué prise
prise à équiper trois noms pour prendre
dame prend kébé 3 pour jouer la casa 5
c'est aussi une option là là il ya
tellement d'options
il ya tellement d'options ici les a mis
là il faut être costaud à il ya plus de
caméra assez terrible
moi je sais pas
beaucoup d'eau si on peut aussi juste en
pot et jouer four b2 pour surprise prise
joue avec des quatre merengues magnus il
m'a pas l'air serein dans ce tournoi non
j'ai besoin qu'il a pris un peu de poids
magnus
dit fatigué neige et l'impression que
visuellement j'ai l'impression qu'il a
pris un peu de poids certain que c'est
pas une attaque du physique fin dire
quelqu'un a pris du poids tu regardes
les matchs de rugby tu vois un gars à un
pilier ou quoi qui étudie la perdu du
poids il a gagné du poids ou ses olives
ont je crois qu'ils avaient perdu un peu
de poids justement aldric peut-être hall
yvon je sais plus 3,4 kg quelque chose
comme ça et ça ça peut changer beaucoup
de choses
en gros si ce fait la même remarque
c'est surtout le confinement bon sens et
pas apprécié le confinement quoi mais
visuellement jambes sont qu'il a
vraiment pris dizaines de kilos après je
sais pas forêt je sais pas c'est des
conférences de presse où il en a parlé
mais ça peut ça peut jouer négativement
sur les performances 1 attention
je ne sais pas si s'il en a parlé
parler dans une dans une conférence de
presse ou pas mais c'est pas
quelque chose d'anodin les échecs ça
demande quand même une bonne condition
physique et magnus on sait qu'il aime en
plus pressé les positions et les parties
pendant des heures et une baisse de
régime physique pourrait pourrait lui
être préjudiciable surtout à la vue de
son style de jeu
donc
je disais qu'il allait prendre sa
première vue le plus cool plus logique
donc je vais montrer des prend et dire
que c'était mauvais mais en fait je suis
pas sûr que ce soit mauvais du tout en
haut des prend va y avoir des idées de
ces quatre en plus ce qu'on apprend
entre son point et son style de jeu à
magnus c'est un joueur
bon alors déjà pour tous les joueurs il
vaut mieux être fit un être en
excellente condition physique
mais magnus c'est quelqu'un qui aime
jouer pendant les positions pendant
longtemps et épuiser l'adversaire
physiquement pour le pousser à l'erreur
et c'est pas un joueur tu râles ami réel
talent ou un chat qui joue vraiment sur
des coups de butoir en milieu de jeu
même si dans tous les cas il faut une
bonne hygiène de vie mais je leur
parlais que magnus c'est un joueur en
plus qui a ajouté ou encore augmenter ce
côté physique aux échecs quoi donc être
en excellente condition physique
c'est plutôt une bonne chose
le côté endurance est un joueur très
endurant
et prend ses 5 est-ce que fois troyen
coup alors faut à 3 l'idée c'est bête
c'est fou prend ses 5 et prend 1,5 et
surtour 8 je vous demandais si j'avais
du cac et prend 1,55 des quatre paris si
ça marche mais ça peut être une option
bon c'est pas du tout ce qui l'a suivi
il a ajoué apprise prises et x 3
il a pas dû vouloir laisser les
histoires et cavaliers prend 1,4
alors peser 5 euros de plus quand elle
dit sur une chaîne stéréo monde durant
question sérieuse ça comme c'est vous
avez vite pour les joueurs qui ont déjà
joué des parties d'échecs de 6,7 eur
vous savez très bien de quoi ça parle
hein c'est vraiment c'est vraiment usant
physiquement et c'est difficile de
maintenir un niveau de concentration
optimale du pouvait évidemment il ya une
dimension physique qui rentrent qui
rentre en compte du coût faire faire du
sport
plusieurs fois par semaine du cardio etc
c'est forcément positif
donc x 3 et je crois qu'il a joué tour
huit tours eu d'accord autour vitam bien
parti donc il veut jouer des quatre
protéger le pion aux quatre surprotéger
de points 4 avec la dame et au passage
il tape un petit coup sûr b5
c'est joli comme quoi dame bien donc
ya pas assez de vue comparé au jour
d'avant malek maggie joue parce qu'en
france on s'en fiche un peu de manioc
j'ai envie de te dire c'est un petit peu
ça la raison d'un bien bien jouer un tap
sur b5 protège 4 à baba qui dit fin bien
évidemment tout cas dame bien
c'est bien joué ça tape de partout
parce qu'ils jouent ici mais je penserai
adam b6 à première vue mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya du cavalier c4 qui peut jaillir
ou même du c4 pour poser problème sur
sur le pion b5 et sur fous ces six ce
qui vaut des quatre qui on prend qui on
prend et après lui planter un dessin qui
gagnera un temps ça peut être très fort
ça qui a écrit repartir et chez parents
17-10 on allait affronter 6
c'est terrible ce yvan 17 il ya quelque
chose qui va pas visuellement c'est pas
les les bonnes cases pour les bonnes
pièces c'est plutôt le fou en b 7 et le
carélien c6 normalement là on a la pièce
longue rangée devant et la pièce courte
longue portée devant et la pièce courte
portée derrière donc ça c'est pas tout à
fait normal en tout cas complexes
complexe complexe et magnus qui est de
nouveau dominé par duda un match
étonnant de la part du joueur polonais
qui semble simplement un peu plus fort
en tout cas sur ces trois jours de
compétition que magnus carlsen après
magnus carlsen champion du monde numéro
1 mondial depuis plus de dix ans
maintenant
il en a vu d'autres et il est capable de
retourner le polonais comme une crêpe
ensuite à mai puis se qualifier quand il
à l'écart de niveau avec ses concurrents
et plus faible qu'avant j'ai
l'impression tu veux dire qu'il a pas
plus faible qu'avant n'en est pas un
énorme gap entre maxime et ses
adversaires avant enfin y'a pas de gap
en fait c'est du cinquante c'est du 50
donc il a fait pousser 6 les matches
quand maxime il va jouer contre sow
contre un contre un contre un kayak ou
quoi c'est du 50-50 ya jamais eu un gap
ya jamais eu un gap ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre quoi fin c'est toujours très
chaud après ya peut-être quelques
joueurs comme j'avais dire comme les
bonnes comme reach ou qui sont un peu
vieillissant est bon ils sont encore
très fort et il ya une nouvelle
génération qui monte donc annoncer tout
le temps du 50 50 1 ces matches là c'est
toujours du 50-50
donc fou c6 mathieu qui lui dit que
l'ordinateur surpuissant cc propose ses
4 donc j'imagine que c'est avec l'idée
sur pions prend de jouer cavalier prend
et de venir taper sur des six avec le
positionnement des pièces blanches est
plus intéressant si on regarde le ils
sont pareils les cavaliers sont sur les
mêmes case le fou c'est 6
c'est le pendant du fou à 3
il faut à 3 tape sur le faible alors que
le fossé site stap sur le dur et le fou
g7 c'est le pendant du fou ces deux est
en quelque sorte le fou ces deux peuvent
rapidement devenir verbe et trois étapes
et donc ouais je peux comprendre
qu'après ces quatre qui on prend
cavaliers prendre les blancs soient
mieux donc ces 4 semble semble logique
une fois qu'on fin logique quand on sait
que c'est le meilleur coup d'après leur
dit on peut comprendre que ce soit un
bon coup après ici évidemment tu as
aussi envie de regarder des 4 1 puis on
prend pions prendrait valeur dit quoi la
turbine est ok seul coup pour jouer
l'égalité b4 avec kid et sur dame prend
b4 de prendre quatre donc ça des villes
adam et si on prend du fou il prend 4
quand même hein il va prendra en haut
rhin et prendre 4 ok mais ça c'est très
dur avoir fait avoir des cations prend
pions prend et b4 pour jouer une double
de déviation donc souvent des villes fou
on force à damas les reins et on gagne 4
soit à la dame vient prendre b4 et on
gagne 4 ça c'est très difficile à voir
comme coup dans de loin b4
b4 b4 et un coup difficile à voir dans
la variante pions décathlon préemption
prend b4 mais ça peut être dans le règne
de magnus
ça peut être dans le règne du magnus
du coup d'absence il joue dès 4 ans
peut-être qu'il sera pas moins bien
après un mets clairement hyper v y
perdrait tout son avantage ray
m'amuse pas son bien lourd à la deuxième
place candidats aux troisièmes dans le
saumon l'a peut-être trouver d'autres
façons c'est quelque chose à voir de
loin
maintenant la question c'est est ce que
duda le voit et si la réponse est oui
qu'est-ce qui va jouer
et ça lui a brisé h qu'on va voir on est
dans l'interrogation les amis
ça réfléchit il ya eu des cas travail à
hull des 4 puis on prend puis on prend
et là c'est le b quattro très dur à
trouver très très difficile à voir et
s'était vu de loin par magnus le saumon
qui s'échappe
assas a été raté par duda et sai et
magnus est dans son match et ils
répondent aux coups de butoir du joueur
polonais on va dire que c'est la
première fois sur sur les trois parties
que manu surpasse vraiment largement
calcul
le joueur polonais est la b4 il avait
pas ce n'était pas dans son daniel où il
avait peut-être il a fait couper 2 du
coup on peut-être que c'était dans son
daniel avoir alors est ce qu il ya de la
complication derrière ça nous on est
forcément retard 1 par rapport aux
joueurs mais sur flu b2 il va peut-être
y avoir du b3 qui part à l'essai chaud
est-ce que magnus avait le four b2 ou
pas j'ai l'impression que duda avait
levé 4 et qu'il a le four b2 en plus
terrible voilà les deux hommes se
rendent coup pour coup elle assez
incroyable parce que l'idée maintenant
c'est il faut avoir le b3 derrière avec
une re déviation pour taper le pion aux
quatre c'est assez extraordinaire
cb trois fous des trois la ligne c'est
terrible
c'est terrible c'est extrêmement
compliqué et au final c'est peut-être
duda way qui surpasse karl scène
exactement ga'hoole
c'est peut-être finalement duda qui a
encore un coup de plus que le champion
du monde qui va 6 1 dans cette demi
finale de coupe du monde ça joue
très très bien côté polonais on voit que
on voit qu'en réalité c'est duda qui a
un temps d'avancé sur son adversaire
car le sel il avait pas le fou b2 il ne
l'avait pas les amis ça clique pas du
tout hasard côté pologne ont peut-être
que le norvégien va utiliser la
technique baptiste anezho un petit peu
comme vous at-il à vallet baky en quarts
de finale pour être en capacité
d'utiliser en 2000 clic au hasard on va
bientôt le savoir
terrible ça transpire il va falloir
cliquer au hasard voilà c'est vraiment
la technique bac islandaise qu'il faut
utiliser dans ces moments là c'est quoi
qui j'avais trois fous des trois bombes
on verra on a le temps voilà tout clic
au hasard qui peut qui peut faire la
diff un bon le b3 qui part ça y est ça
clique au hasard très bien joué le
hasard comme d'habitude fait bien les
choses le eden hazard qui n'a pas amené
de titres à la belgique mais qui va
peut-être enlevé une épine du pied à
karl scène donc le b3 qui part alors
cette technique pakistanaise du kick au
hasard qui peut faire très mal à 12
heures il n'a peut-être pas très bien
juger le truc
et donc si on prend ce fait dévier une
pièce son père le pion aux 4
va faire foot est roi et sur cavaliers à
quatre on verra si mini magnus au dessus
n'a pas vu les parties d'avant-hier
eddie herr probablement mais là c'est
vrai que si semble avoir réellement bien
joué là il semble vraiment bien joué il
est bien magnus est possible qu'ils
soient bien possible position est
complexe
la position est très compliqué et ce
avec le b3 a surpris de duda en tout cas
il n'avait pas ils avaient jusqu'à four
b2 il a sous-estimé b3 on va voir
il a aussi dépensé 5 voilà j'avais vous
en parler au moment où il a été joué
pour tout liquider prise prise prise
prises et ça va rendre qu'à prendre 4 il
va y avoir la b2 enlève alors maintenant
ça va prendre ses 5es sur reprises ces
cinq
il va prendre 4 prendre 4 prendre 4
ondra u8 andra 8 et revenir et prendre
des deux prendre b2 voilà c'est ça la
ligne hockey ont pris ces cinq prises
c56 prend 1,8 la dame reprend et ça va
partir en 4s qui peut prendre f6 prendra
huit prendre ces 5
et quand il prend le cas de prendre
quatre prendre 4 prendre qu'à prendre 4
et ça va être nul
moi je sens que ça tire de partout pour
magnus
et qu'est-ce qu'il a bien joué la grosse
défense a
qu'est-ce qui nous a sortis comme
défense magnus ce que là ya tellement
d'options pour les blancs est ce qu'il
ya eu 5 5 et qui a aidé cette a le
niveau de jeu est vraiment incroyable
côté magnus
ça joue bien qui vient un petit coup de
panique il a regardé la pendule a
paniqué ça s'est vu un visuellement la
sur la cam il a eu le petit coup petit
coup de stress
il a peut-être pas de gains tout
simplement moi ce que 5 et qui a aidé 5
peut-être je sais pas si inquiets des
cinq visuellement iv dame français 5
pour moi mais j'en sais rien
tout cas c'était tellement bien joué de
la part de magnus toute la série de
coups là à partir de b4 était vraiment
très impressionnante
mais reste plus que neuf minutes 20 pour
duda
à voir comment ils continuent
ça paraît pas évident tout ça en gros
plan blizzard a les caméras aujourd'hui
on va laisser aller c'est un peu gros
plan sur jean-christophe
bon là il ya plein d'options pour
simplement faire nul 1 jean christophe
peut-être falloir se résigner à
apprendre le demi point
quel calcul
il se fait saumonade elle n'arrive pas
il trouve pas
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a joués on va
rechange et la cam il a joué cavalier e
5 j'ai bien l'impression tap le four
peut-être c'est une option intéressante
et franchement ça rajoute de la
complexité à la complexité
frais en outaouais c'est en fait cessé
ses parents qui sont francophiles je
crois et qui du coup lui en donnaient un
prénom français
qui avait lieu 5 menace le fou français
5 honnêtement la cedh est juste même
difficile à commenter parce que c'est
très concret
complexe le carrier en tout cas qui tape
sur ces 6 soit il va y avoir foule
bessette noter que la turbine propose x
4 pour jouer sur la déviation de la dame
et prendre des deux à la fin
c'est tellement compliqué mais fou à 4
il peut le trouver
il fait des déviations depuis tout à
l'heure
complexe
puis minutes pour les deux hommes x 4
vraiment durable quant à trouver des
cadres des trois et toutes les
déviations j'ai l'impression que c'est
dans leur haine genre tu peux y aller
jusqu'au bout après un tu peux trouver
jusqu'au bout
ce que je souhaite c'est ticket prend
ses 7,7 peut-être impossible possible
qu'il y ait un
la position est vraiment vraiment
difficile les deux joueurs qui se
rendent coup pour coup et qui joue une
partie d'un très haut niveau ont cette
demi finale de coupe du monde
et l'envoyer x 4 il n'ya pas d'un procès
sakhir adam prend des deux c'était sur
qui le trouverait ça c'était largement
dans son règne
elle a les deux les deux les deux
joueurs les meilleurs courants ya plus
de il ya plus de bluff
là ça joue fort donc faire d'hamsik adam
des deux dames f7 c'est la question à
ces questions que je me pose aussi mais
a dû tout reprendre cinq ans et
regardait
très complet
la position est très complexe
là ça joue très très fort alors est-ce
qui va tenter dame c4 est ce qu'il va
jouer plus sagement dame c1
j'aimerais bien tenter le drame france
écartent le dame c4 en fait vite la
ligne ça doit être ça sonntag français
45.5 dame prend des deux il n'ya pas ton
point katia dame prend gens fous ces
trois menaces la dame tap le food and 17
seul coup 5 qui avait les dessins
qu'elle aille à rien ça le problème
ok c'est ultra compliqué avec la turbine
est c'est plus facile mais c'est à al
ayyat à chaque fois il ya quatre cinq
options et le truc c'est qu'elles sont
toutes toujours jouable
c'est difficile de choisir en fait y en
a pas une qui est vraiment mauvaise ou
l'autre vraiment bonne
adam prend quatre pages aux abords d'un
point 4.634 entier pénible
et si on prend deux fois avec la tour en
premier puis avec la dame ya des deux
qui tombe qu'il a fait tout reprend dame
prend et donc il a tout pris par entrer
dans le drame c 4 alors attendez la pria
cathy va voir prises des deux et là
c'est dommage pour lui qui n'arrive pas
à prendre et 6 pour taper 8
il a joué damart et ultra logique ça
c'était une des variantes qu'on avait
regardé ouais il veut cavaliers f3 est
fou prend f6 endroit
ultra complexes
il y en a
partout avec cette batterie qui peut
être pénible il peut peut-être faire un
cavalier h5 en fait pour taper ici
cavale et c4 fou prend b2 qui avait
prend des deux fous prend un tour points
et ça ça doit être nul quasiment sûr
défense de magnus encore aujourd'hui qui
fait aucune erreur dans une position a
vraiment vraiment difficile s'en sort
bien
oh ce cavalier g4 war si on prend fou
prend 1,5 fou prend 1,5 to reprend 1,5
et si on reprend 1,5 isle adam un échec
sur tour des uns fait quand même peur
jusqu'à la tour qui arrive monde et 8
mais peut-être qu'il adam g 5 annoncée à
c'est tellement chaud partout je pense
qu'ils vont tous trouvé jusqu'au bout il
faut tellement bien les deux après à
vrai dire là ya pas vraiment possibilité
de faire une grosse erreur il a fait
cavaler h s'inquiétait le coup j'avais
regardé moi aussi sans ordi
il est parti sur cavaliers h5
on va voir arriver sur le grand
échiquier
donc ils menacent de prendre 5 et je
m'attends vraiment une liquidation
massive 1 et a eu nul qui arriverait
voyage 5 il a fait pousser 3 d'accord il
veut fou prend 1,5 fou prend des deux
fous prend un tour - tours prend 4 est
ici peut-être tour c1 et venir s'en
prendre aux pions
toujours pas arrivé à l'écran je pense
est salutaire
terrible
c'est sûr qu'il va jouer ça et que ça va
faire nul
ouais ben du coup car c'est d'avoir les
blancs dans la deuxième il va pouvoir
faire mal non il va boucher saddam il va
jouer le gain en fait tams et 2 veut pas
deux nuls magnus
la retraite est un truc qui le
dérangeait 1
c'est chaud bouillant ils menacent quoi
la magnus
alors il ya quoi ils dament ces deux
dames à cette dame b3 dont qui menaçait
dame prend f7 sur fou prend 1,5
son idée c'était fou prend 1,5 et on
prend 1,5 et d'amd 8 donc avec cette
petite double attaque n'est donc damas
cette dame b3 news qui doit vouloir
jouer le gain c'est vraiment
extraordinaire là ce qui fait le joueur
norvégien race et duda qui a fini par
craquer quelle défense de magnus
parce que maintenant il ya fou prend un
sens qui rôdent sur vous prend 15.5 y
aura plus d'un bep 8
du coup d'un b3 il a peut-être
sous-estimé duda et sur dame français
saint qui va voir du cavalier 4 qui a
aidé 3 qui va jaillir terrible roi les
deux hommes qui sont rendus vraiment
coup pour coup ça joue beaucoup trop
bien et sur dan 17 c'est quoi le bail
j'ai regardé avec l'ordi parce que dame
17 sa part fo ramia cavaliers à 6 août
ou aouda me 6 ou la dame eux s'ils
souhaitent échanger gagnent grâce au
courage donc et une dame français cinq
cavaliers qui va jaillir en f4 et qui va
menacer cavaliers detroit ont ça sent
pas bon pour jean-christophe
il fait mal il ya cavaliers detroit qui
peut roter dans des variantes
il ya des cavaliers eux deux qui peuvent
rodez à la menace est simple 1 c'est fou
prendre 5 fu prend aux cinq cavaliers
detroit
donc il va être obligé de faire ton re3
pour couvrir sa troisième rangée et sa
caste et 3
ça sent pas bon ça ne sent pas bon pour
jean christophe c'est terrible c'est
terrible pour le joueur polonais il va
la perdre trop gourmand finalement
magnus qui a sorti une défense
incroyable et il fallait pour
jean-christophe prendre la décision de
de faire nul et d'aller voir la
prochaine partie après on peut le
comprendre il semble dominer depuis
depuis la première journée il passe
proche de la victoire
déjà plusieurs reprises et aujourd'hui
on a peut-être un peu trop me mais là ça
en sus retour aux 3 il va y avoir des
dames d un qui a valu aux deux pour
menacer de mater avec du dam g1
on voit qu'il est dépassé 1 par les
événements
ou alors 10 0 c'est à dire que c'est pas
perdant ah ben non meilleur coût d'un
égal 1 mais c'est l'intérêt des
commentaires on commente un peu
l'émotion et ce qui est en train de se
passer dans les parties sur ta mena il a
encore tout autant pour tous au vais
peut-être aller il faut aller il faut
aller chercher la défense là il est
proche de craquer maintenant
jean-christophe mais il a peut-être
encore un une petite ouverture pour
tirer la drôme
peut-être peut-être il lui reste plus
que 25 secondes et d'amd un tour où il
n'a pas le vent il sortirait par la
petite porte
il s'en sortir par la petite porte
arrière duda après damas cette dame b 3
dames c5 manu savez le cavaliere quattro
il avait les coûts magnus mais c'est
peut-être cette fois-ci duda qu'à voir
le petit supplément de réussite
nous propose fou prend 1,5 cinq dames d
un rouage de cavaliers eux deux sa force
sa menace d'alger en maths ça forcerait
tout reprendre deux d'entre eux deux et
peut-être qu'il peut jouer un dam des
quatre avec les casses faible autour du
roi et sa qui sait ça pourrait même
tourner de l'autre côté avait pas de bol
pour magnus ça aurait pu être gagnant ça
aurait pu être gagnant mais par un trou
de souris duda réussi à rester en vie
reste plus beaucoup de temps maintenant
pour magnus on est sur du 2 minutes 20
il aura réussi à garder la tête froide
et à trouver les seuls coûts allaient
magnus qui part sur dame d un tour e 1
c'est bien pour jean christophe qui joue
tempo il l'avait salle touré récupère 10
secondes la news qui va probablement
repartir sur le dame b 3 on va revenir à
la position initiale
le cav a lieu deux intermédiaires
rouages de doit pas passer
il ya aussi du damage 5 qui peut être
intéressant ici pour jouer sur des
multiples clouage ça peut être un coup
ça peut être un coup à voir si c'est ce
qui joue ou pas
en tout cas magnus la dame d un tour il
espère avoir quelque chose ici mais
finalement c'est lui qui se met mal
autant et si fait d'un bep trois tours
troyes je pense qu'il prendra la nulle
maintenant magnus il veut pas rentrer
dans la dans la position avec le fou qui
tape
allez on va voir ce qui fait mon magnus
plus qu'une minute maintenant pour le
champion du monde norvégien
il a l'air déçu à ne pas avoir de gains
dame b3 joué tour 3 tempo doute à qui
veut pas perdre la moindre seconde qui
récupère encore 10 secondes c'est bien
joué de la part du polonais allait ce
que magnus tant que la position avec une
cale de plus qui peut se retourner
contre lui ou est ce que y
il joue plutôt la sécurité en bon père
de famille alors qu'il n'est pas père de
famille mais il pourrait jouer en père
de famille et prendre le demi point et
essayer de mettre la pression avec les
blancs dans la prochaine
d'un autre côté s'ils gagnent maintenant
avec les noirs y clôture quasiment le
match aller plus de 27 secondes en dame
d un il va jouer la lap l'autre aip le
13 dam des trois tours troyes et ça va
répéter ouais ladro qui est signée
magnus qui a décidé de jouer la gestion
et de pas rentrer dans la variante fou
prend 1 500 prend 1 5 dames d un roi h2k
va lieu de deux d'entre eux deux ils
adulent à la regarder pendant un moment
celle là avec d'amd 4 et il faut à suite
qui menaçait l'ordi données d'un match 5
comme une option avec l'idée sur fois je
suis d'avoir damage 6 pour couvrir mais
c'est vrai qu'avec un roi aussi faible
ça semblait difficile à gagner
magnus qui ne la joue même pas et qui
prend et qui prend là nul le twr éclairé
ne dit maxime être éclairé mais plutôt
quand même maxime
le truc quand même le clic au hasard
demandé de faire front aux 5,1 à l'est
la page au hasard il a pris la nulle de
manière volontaire et donc il va falloir
revenir pour le match retour dans une
dizaine de minutes ne va pas partir ou
sage ou encore de ce côté là avec moi tu
pour la troisième place de la coupe du
monde féminine
voilà sa part on put instantanément
cubed
on pense très clairement très clairement
on voit les deux rois qui sont un sur
casse blanche et noire le roi blanc sur
blanc le roi noir sur noir ce qui
signifie que la partie s'est terminée
par une nulle et magnus qui n'a pas
rangé sa dame b3 qui reste il n'a pas
fini de ranger ses pièces terrible
peut-être que les arbitres devraient
intervenir sur cette dame b 3
st
la pub qui est là qui est bien présente
qui fait mal à tout le monde
ça reprend dans des dix minutes ou pas
si on attend du coude a maintenant mis à
le match pour la troisième place
si on met les bras sur une couleur
séguin bas 6 les deux rois sont sur
blanc ses gains blanc si les droits sont
sur noir séguin noir au centre et si les
rois sont sur blanc et noir c'est drôle
à voir comment si nice est parti un
risque aux apparences et les pièces rien
ce qui est toujours bien via domitia
chez les femmes
est ce qu'il ya le même système louis à
partir de ce cycle là il ya le même
système avec des grands prix la coupe du
monde et c'est la partie terminée c'est
pas de simplement là ça part tout de
suite en jeu vous dire quel résultat il
ya eu ce qui est une répétition il se
passe quelque chose de bizarre c'est eux
c'est anne qui a gagné les deux rois
sont sur noir donc c'est les noirs qui
ont gagné le tannat tenue tan qui va
peut-être aller chercher une place au
candidat te et move illégal complexe un
move illégal en rapide s'était fait
tomber autant arriver à tomber autant ou
pas je sais pas si c'était ton beau
temps au moment au moment fatidique en
tout cas
car la partie est terminée on range les
pièces côte arbitrage intéressant là le
gros plans l'arbite qui va réussir à
mettre les pièces sur les bonnes cases
c'est bien joué à la dame qui part sur
sa couleur c'est maîtrisé ml maîtrise
côte arbitres allaient tour qui viennent
dans les coins les fous à côté de la
dame et du roi les tours et les
cavaliers côte à côte les pions sur la
deuxième rangée c'est très très bien
joué la position ici mais tricot est
magnifique magnifique ça a doublé pièce
allez on est on est sur du placement de
pièces très karité ou le pion à 2 qui
revient bien sûr sa case le pion à deux
un peu décalé là quand même aller ouais
voilà on remet les pions sur une
deuxième rangée c'est bien joué
magnifique
le papier et le stylo qui s'en vont et
la table qui va pouvoir être laissée
vacante avant l'arrivée des joueuses
voilà il ya un petit peu de notation
quand même un pour être bien sûr
extraordinaire à la sa note
voilà sa note les résultats et ça repart
vers la table d'arbitrage alors que le
caméraman ne suis pas l'action arbitres
cas rien
arbitre carried alors qu'on nous montre
pas le chrono aujourd'hui côté régis je
pense que ça doit reprendre à 15h10 au
plus tard avec une deuxième plus bas les
pubs qui partent
le droit de recentrer la position de ces
pièces selle son adversaire oui mais il
faut dire chalhoub avant sinon t'as
palois
donc on va attendre la partie retour ça
devrait démarrer un rapidement
ce à 15h10 soit qu'un entre 15h10 et
15h15
désigné plus haut bois précieux pourquoi
on fait ça on verra quoi tu vaux pas
mieux sur un échiquier en bois précieux
donc
il réagissait à la fin du tournoi ou pas
oui enfin en septembre là du coup je
vais aller je vais me prendre un petit
truc à manger je reviens dans 3 min
je retourne les gars j'ai profité pour
manger un petit truc et boire un petit
peu parce que c'est un excellent on en
fait j'ai la chance que ma femme acheter
du pain du pain reçu par le roi noir
russe super bon du coup c'était terrible
avec un petit peu de beurre c'est
terrible c'est trop irrésistible pain
noir doit être au bon le pain noir us et
c'est vraiment beaucoup trop surtout
quand ça fait longtemps que tu en as pas
manger
ouaip en noir avec un noir us avec du
beurre c'est trop c'est trop dessus
k
à lire est il resté de game je crois que
ça va repartir en vrai alors attendez ce
qu'on peut avoir la cadre est donc c'est
tout avec les noirs toujours en chemise
blanche et magnus ce qu'on voit pas mais
qu'ils en fassent un forcément les pins
noirs seront ça peut être pas mal aussi
d'ailleurs
la finale se joue en même temps que la
finale wpt a complètement la finale se
jouera en même temps que la finale ça
c'est sûr
ça va partir en attend là les amis
qui annule dans la première
on est maintenant sur le retour je m le
score
je vais mettre le score je vais afficher
le score on va voir si ça va être du
coup duda qui appuie sa part de 4 c 5
une sicilienne
donc il n'a pas rejoué des quatre caves
et des f3 des 6 es fou bessines qu'aux
échecs ça joue côté magnus comme
contrebas qui il va y avoir un étau de
ma roxy vous allez le voir
je viens de dire est ce que la finale se
joue en même temps que la demi-finale or
difficile de jouer la finale en même
temps puisque la finale se jouera entre
le vainqueur des deux demi finales donc
arias qui n'est là on est en train de
décider du deuxième finaliste en ce
moment donc ce serait difficile de jouer
la finale en même temps complexe
je comprends pas j'ai toujours
l'impression que c'est un maroc s'est
améliorée mais femme avait l'air de dire
que c'était complexe assez complexe mais
c'est complexe puisque d'un côté il ya
plus le fou de cases blanches il arriva
pas jouer le maroc s'il va jouer avec
ces trois des quatre mais d'un autre
côté les noirs sont contents d'avoir
échangé une pièce donc il ya des
avantages et des inconvénients des deux
côtés d'avoir échangé les fous de cases
blanches la petite finale se joue en
même temps que la finale
ah oui ça oui la petite finale la finale
se joue en même temps et donc c'est
théorique ça ressemble à la partie
serait pas la partie n'est pas au bac
qui grande chez store paris cette année
qui avait été une turbo défaite du
président pakistanais
c'est n'importe quoi c'est n'importe
quoi
donc prises des deux rangs des deux
c'est pareil bas qui avaient fait à 5 et
qui s'était fait mater rapidement avec
avec une tour qui était passé sur la
couche sur la troisième
je crois que c'était sabah qui a dû
faire à 5 ans était à 5 à 3 à 4 non
la partie baciu jeu où je joue je délire
la jouer fou b4 qui était rare ouais je
me rappelle bien éviter que voulait
faire à 5 pour faire flamber 4 et
pouvoir reprendre du pillon un truc
comme ça mais c'était vraiment mauvais
peut-être pas exactement cette position
mais il faut faire hyper gaffe côté noir
au autour qui passe sur la troisième
parce que oui une française sont les
fous de cases blanches bon pour les
noirs c'est plus compliqué que ça quand
même pascal go là on est plus sur des
échecs niveau club à qui avait perdu en
27 28 coup cette structure contre les
pots sans les fous de cases blanches ça
peut aller
mon très vite qu'ils arrivent manger 5 à
tours angers 3 l'adamant h5 c'est déjà
ma tu changes semble étrange pourquoi
échangé le bon football et blanc un
avantage des espaces du coup mauvais fou
dans l' avantage des espaces c'est pas
forcément si mauvais que ça
b quattro a foulé quattro qui est parti
il vous prend les quatre qu'il prendrait
quatre tours c1
ça peut être une option ça quelque chose
comme ça mais moi il n'aura jamais le
temps d'aller attaquer en fait cela
donne l'impression que tu as le temps de
colmater
elle semble assez égale bobby fischer 2
suis d'accord avec toi mais je voulais
juste te dire que ça c'est peut-être
loin x égal que ça n'y paraissent ces
présidents avaient perdu le genre de
structure très rapidement et très
facilement c'est parce que c'est plus
complexe
ça réfléchit côté duda 1 pourrait même
tenter grand quest c'est vrai j'aime pas
du tout mais ce serait pas stupide ça
devrait terminer en nul après un ca on
est d'accord ne pensez pas que que je
donne victoire blanche favorites ici
mais je veux juste se dire attention ça
paraît vraiment nulles nulles mais en
fait il faut faire garder un magnus
garde le foot cazin fff 4 c'est à dire
qu'il veut vraiment jouer pour la taxe
sur le roi
petit rock envoyé regarder chez sky fin
effectivement n'est pas effet invoquer
le tour 6 3 contre le président
engrangés sur parra mais ça c'est sûr
est la partie me rappelle mes mais
est-ce que c'était cette variante
exactement rock rock et il a joué dames
3 je crois faut faire gaffe
ben ça peut aller très vite qui a rédigé
5 d'un match 3 ou fou f4 et la jolie
dame détroit avant c'est pareil kg 5
damage froid tout ça ça peut aller très
vite
et peut-être joué fossati 6 et du coup
ils changent et si ça arrive angers 5
c'est ce qu'il a joué il a ramené le
four set et j'ai cinq affiches très bon
après le prime sera dame prend 1,7
markham est ce que c'est vrai que manu
c'est moins fort en blitz écoute il est
champion du monde de blitz sa part et ne
pas être le cas
j'arrive à empêcher qu'ils avaient g5
bizarre de reboucher la même pièce on
dit dans le chat de bain le fou b4 à
pourra provoquer fouet f4 donc
maintenant et mes envies en recettes on
a quand même le droit de jouer deux fois
la même pièce aux échecs heureusement et
il a joué à trois minutes donc à 300
pêche et cavaliers b4 ça permet de bien
installer la dame
donc voilà sûrement tours fc 8 pour ses
sept tours s'éviter jouer la colonne
c'est avec peut-être dû cavaler à 5 car
les c4 par la suite
sept tours fc 8
il a joué tour à ses 8 j'aurais plutôt
est parti avec la f pour me donner soit
du fuite soit du food et 8 soit due qu'à
valider 8 mais ma foi je vois pas de
problème avec tour à ses 8 lui veut se
garder du f6 donc c'est aussi assez
logique
mais après tout ça doit pas changer
grand chose
normalement devrait pas y avoir de
regret dans cette partie
donc paris ne dit pas que manu c'est
beau gosse anglais sûrement jamais vu en
vrai c'est terrible c'est pas du tout en
s y tiennent cocoyes cas très loin de là
elle photoshopée d'un peut-être mais là
on en est quand même très loin
non mais bon là c'est pas un back in on
bon là non riesch championne du monde
c'est un très bon joueur d'échecs ou
quoi mais demandent qu'un quand même
c'est quand même c'est quand même
particulier quoi
donc il a joué cavalier à 5 bon il va
peut-être faire dans macadam detroit ou
quelque chose comme ça et il peut être
même un peu mieux à terme
cain
à 5 je pense qu'il va faire b3 pour un
peu tout empêcher mais bon du coup à
trois baies 3 c'est bizarre
il a joué b3 et comme prévu mais bon ben
non ça c'est ça va j'ai 3 il va
peut-être vouloir faire h4 qui avale et
g5 et sur foot rangée 5 algérois j'ai
deux tours h1 et c'est ça le plan de
magnus ch 4 kg 5 fu bouffe algérois j'ai
deux tours agen
donc il va peut-être jouer à 6 et dames
b5
ouais
non là je pense que ça va être ça
je pense à 6 à 6 dames bessengue pour
échanger les dames et pas laisser la
taxe sur le roi peut-être sur a6 il va
faire fou des deux caves à laisser si
ch4 faut être précis encore côté bas des
deux côtés en fait c'est une partie qui
peut théoriquement tourner d'un côté ou
de l'autre
on va voir
on va vous
donc un gars qui réfléchit complexe
gi joe a accueilli ces six mois je suis
assise dame b 5 pourrait changer
essayez du coup s'il fait des cas de
mathieu cavalié ans et 4
ça réfléchit en tout cas côté polonais
taqiya pèse le pour et le contre
c'est à voir les blancs sur cette
position ouais mais c'est pas sûr que je
me fasse pas contre et moi je peux
vouloir trop en faire avec les blancs là
on va voir ainsi adieu à six qui part ou
pas va aussi calculé tour c'est cet ours
et 8 etc
on a plus plus qu une cam sur la demi
finale
bon il a le temps après 25 minutes c'est
long un c'est pas délirant de tank et 10
minutes sur cette position en vrai
faire les noirs et la puissance avec les
blancs c'est pas toi qui va se faire
mater comme un amateur enfin pas une
question matin en amateur c'est juste
que tu crées des menaces en aux échecs
soirée scrutin un gars en face ce qui
est de 1700 tu dois pas l'attaquer quoi
sur 1 6 à 4 pour éviter d'amener sein du
coup ça donnerait cavaliers c6 qui
arrivent et 4
serez vous pas un peu macho n'en serait
que les parties des hommes h montre le
tournoi mixte je regarde je regarde le
tournoi mixte en fait h à 58 140 ou non
c'est un tournoi auquel participent et
hommes et femmes un tournoi non excluant
terrible nan nan c'est pas du tout le
tournoi hommes c'est plutôt cette
remarque qui est étrange terrible il a
joué peut-être cavani ses 6 en moyenne
c'est quoi la durée de vie d'un joueur
pro pas je pense comme tout le monde un
75 81 ans je pas exactement
l'espérance de vie aujourd'hui
on va venir en c1 mais j'ai raté des
coups mais je pense cet ours est en
cours il ya aussi fou des deux il a fait
tomber 1 et sur dame ces deux il veut
quoi ah non pardon j'ai raté les queens
il fout des deux dames b6 tourbe est un
pardon et à les cookies sont arrivés en
grappes et le fou des deux pour dévier
la dame en b6 et tourbe et maintenant ça
me paraissait bizarre ce que je
comprenais c'est pas le bail / dams et
de jeu voyait pas le bail
k
on jouerait pas du tour ces six torcé 8
une énorme mieux ses manies s'attaque
pas aux f1 après il fait un ces deux
coups en fait son attaque avec son
attaquant il fait h quatre cavaliers g5
et tout de suite après prise free
s'était très vite sur du roi j'ai deux
tours achats en fait
intéressant lecavalier a cinq qui a du
mal à trouver des cases en fait qu'il a
passé 4 il ya pas b4 il n'y a pas eu 5
et des cas très bien protégés
bon
comment est ce que jean christophe va
évoluer ici je savais que même su
rameuter tout à vrai dire sur ces deux
ça fait pas grand chose
complexe
janin gresh prions de seniors
intéressant qui viennent jamais regarder
non plus en fait
donc il a joué à six donc il veut ta
tâche 4 6 6 3 g ii d'amd 5 et récupère
ce plan intéressant à 6
ainsi c'est intéressant est vraiment
bien duda g2 je pensais cavaliers si si
si si
danb et 5 mai il mettra la dame en a
trois
c'est bloqué la poussée du plomb mais
aussi pas je pense pas qu b4 bessin qui
était une idée puisque le câble et ses
revenus en verre à cinq essais 4 je
pense que vraiment d'un bep 5 en fait
c'est très complexe il peut y avoir des
f6 aussi qu'ils partent après de l'autre
côté
et puis ont doublé c'est pas gênant pas
cela non sont trop durs à attaquer
tours
il se prémunit df 6dans b5 jouer
va sûrement échanger mètres la tour
anciens et ça va faire nul je pense
grosse partie de 12 ans encore il est
vraiment fort ce jean christophe il
envoie un énorme match en jean
christophe réellement à mon avis s'ils
continuent sur cette lancée il va jouer
tab 10 1 il va vraiment s'installer dans
le top 10 mondial si réussi à se
stabiliser à ce niveau de jeu ce soit au
niveau de la prépa ainsi réussi au moins
stabilisés ce niveau de préparation et
continuer à être en forme dans l'est
dans les milieux de jeu et magnus
réussit vraiment pas à le dominer
qui va jouer dame b 1 je veux vraiment
faire le h4 mais attention quand même à
force les pièces blanches deviennent
passive
jean-christophe qui joue tour c'est
cette maintenant c'est leur esprit de
doigts c'est les ouvertures à la base
oui maxime qui voulait faire d'un v6
pour faire le chantage à la drôme mais
pas de chantage ça je vous le gain des
deux côtés dans ses 7 h 4 ça envoie
bref c'est 8 tu veux quoi il va cavale
et g5 on va jeter un oeil un fou pranger
5h et cavaliers prend des quatre tours
has que ça ça passe ça passe pas du tout
il ya cavaliers f5 et tour ces deux
qu'est ce qu'il veut manu sur tours ces
huit son attaque sans pas si puissante
h5 un petit peu il veut essayer de faire
de la carabistouilles est cavale est à
sa 5 4 pour attaquer tour 3 ah je suis
pour bloquer c'est peut-être choain
assez chaud pour les deux en vrai un
vrai c'est chaud parce que tu as du mal
à progresser plus avec les noirs halal
dames c'est quand même bien bloqué mais
d'un autre côté les plantes sont
tellement loin d'attaqué à l'oeil droit
ça peut ressembler allez c'est pas du
tout la même structure mais dans les
carlsbad des fois tu défends ton album
avec la tour tout d'un coup on va du g4
tour g 3g 5 et tu m'as tu donc il a joué
le tours fc 8 ans je crois bien jean
christophe complexe pour pour magnus
-ici- magnus s'incliner à l'haïtien
qu'il s'inclinerait vraiment à la
régulière il aurait trouvé peut-être
plus fort que lui magnus finalement ce
serait terrible hein il pourrait garder
son titre de champion du monde pendant
encore quelques années elle a vu deux
des systèmes qualificatif complexe mais
il fait peut-être moins peur
tours à deux ils couvrent la case ces
deux
tours à deux c'est pas mal joué 1 sur
canal et hassen qui va pouvoir repartir
peut-être avec du tour 3 et il couvre
les cases
complexe il a joué quoi comme tous ici
je n'ai pas vraiment vu c'est peut-être
un fouet fuite à cinq je sais pas du
tout du bon côté début que c'était un
petit coup mais j'avais pas les yeux
rivés sur la caméra
hassen qui veut quand il veut à quatre
ses passes il est pas contre sens en
tout cas tout à fait a minima jeu égal 1
dans ce match
magnus qui subit
mais 12 à ne réussit pas le faire rompre
c'est ça le danger un sais que ça peut
contrer à tout moment
5 bien joué
j'alerte très détendu à la caméra duda
on n'a pas l'impression qu'il est un
complexe d'infériorité par rapport au
champion du monde et 2 à 5 c à 4 je vais
sur les cases blanches mais il faudra y
accéder
est ce qu'il ya des rajouts de temps il
ya simplement 10 secondes de bonus par
coup
soit une française d'une bonne karo kann
pour les noirs après oui mais attention
ça peut tellement envie de tourner un
petit h 5e scache 5 est vraiment fort ça
la question est ce que h 5 h si c'est
vraiment fort pour les blancs ce qu'ils
ont peut-être pas le temps de faire g4
g5
donc ma news va jouer
il a joué tour h11 il envoie il envoie
le jeu sur le roi et il a bien raison
pour agen qui se questionnent peut-être
qu'il va faire du h6 pour éviter les
cavaliers g5
quelles sont les menaces noir on nous
demande dans le chatt bas ce serait de
réussir à rentrer à la lhdaa mais on a
du mal à s'organiser
elle est complexe
je sens que c'est ok pour des quatre
fire adam prend un certain surtout
maxime clinique à 4 kg cinq champions
pranger si ça se tente
si tu veux dire que ça va aller puis on
prend des trois dames argent point de
tonfa hc3 fuite
il n'y a pas de foot et quatre échecs
pour choper le roi à rebrousse poil
maxime en effet qu'il prendrait quatre
c'est encore plus fort je crois que
c'est tenter non par duda le à cuatro
pas le même et chic et non c'est pas
leur échiquier tout ça j'ai l'impression
d'une d'avancé 5 je me disais c'est un
peu bizarre
ça réfléchit côté duda attention de pas
de se mettre trop mal autant non plus
la tâche si ça
tâche 6 pour couvrir
bon
ça réfléchit
certains j'aurais plutôt h6 tranquille
dans le tchat après il faut calculer un
après c'est vraiment du calcul pur et
dur
ses rangs complexe le temps qui file
ils jouent à 4 à lille joue le coup de
maxime duda et ça y est c'est le moment
qui là qu'il a décidé pour mettre le
bordel dans le match il joue b4 magnus
qui part pas dans le cavalier g5
by news qui joue b4 quasiment
instantanément et il est sur le reculoir
le champion du monde norvégien
un b 4 il donne les cases blanches mais
lecavalier n'a pas vraiment accès à la
casse ces 4 maxime qui auraient voulu
avoir le temps de mettre le cavalier
fuite au québec 8 ça peut être un coup
quand même parce qu'une fois en 17 tu
vises beaucoup de cases complexe
il ya des gens qui font ça me saoule et
dans le tchat avec leurs discussions sur
le temps relatif honnêtement je vais
vous band of tous les deux si vous
continuez ça va aller vite au québec qui
est g5 ce que j'étais en train de penser
aussi aider celles qui avaient déjà
fuité on est juste à temps je me disais
exactement ça toi je sais ce qui est des
scènes d'un machin qui a fuité pile à
temps
on verra si le temps du débat ni cement
est relatif
si vous avez pris l'avion complexe on ne
sait pas est ce que le temps d'un ban
def passe plus vite suivant la vitesse
de la lumière
complexe on ne sait pas ce qu'il a joué
à six qu'est ce qui se passe sur chez
quatre maintenant ça peut aller très
vite hein quand même côté côté blanc le
roi duda peut se retrouver en danger
après un dut gsh 5 g 5 ça peut aller
rapidement mal pour les noirs mais mais
magnus à jouer fouet 3 j'ai l'impression
encore un coup de temporisation magnus
une nouvelle fois dominée par le
polonais a il va falloir finir par la
gagner un côté côté jean côté christophe
et j'ai crié crié heba qui pour qu'il
revienne et une chanson de christophe un
bien connu une victoire de duda pourrait
ramener cris baky en match pour la
troisième place à l'est mais les cavs à
lyon a7 maintenant il va pouvoir rentrer
avec la tour en c3 la dame en c4
lecavalier en bessin qu il peut y avoir
du shalala qui part à tout moment
terrible le saumon est en train de cuire
et s'il perd le tout il va partir un
magnus est il encore champion du monde
2 après sa défaite en demi finale
j'annonce déjà le tweet tweet question
qui partira on verra pour vous un ce que
pense twitter est ce que quand tu perds
en demi-finale d'une coupe du monde tu
as encore champion du monde
on ne sait pas est ce que le tour c'est
3 va partir attention évitez d'être car
med a tenté un maxime on tente ça
partira après mais le karma peut partir
bien évidemment est ce qu'il ya des
supporters polonais dans la salle ce
serait mérité en tout cas de les
qualifications 12h15 yakine on aurait
vraiment là les deux plus forts joueur
de la compétition s'affronteront en
finale pour voir qui est le meilleur
joueur d'échecs sur cet été 2021
magnus qui pourraient s'incliner contre
le premier joueur membre du top 20 qu'il
affronte performance que finale serait
assez décevante
allez tour ces trois dames détroit qui a
l'air très fort magnus en sueur et
larmes il fonde et de haut ça commence à
craquer ça commence à craquer côté
saumon il faut trois fous des deux ça
défend comme ça peut hélas du tour c'est
quattro maintenant qui peut partir avec
la dame en c6 la tour en c2 peut-être
donc qui en d2 ça couvre encore là il
doit le sentir un dida qui n'est pas
loin
pour ces quatre dames ces six cavaliers
b5
dam de jean christophe filet c'est une
pénétration centrale mais il n'ya pas
fou prend h6 est complètement con
peut-être aille à tour ces deux non pas
du tout il ya tour ces deux watches tour
ces deux mais il ya peut-être juste
tourer est assez complètement coup en
fait c'est en fait complètement con
terrible
sa force d'âme des cinq retours servent
à rien ça commence à craquer côté
polonais et quand le dit maxime sur dame
ses quatre tours c1 dames 2e tour il va
être obligé de faire dame b 5 premiers
premiers signes de crack allemand coté
côté polonais ex dame de tournai il
maintient son avantage tout de même mais
il a perdu un coup y'a peut-être en
profiter pour repartir vers à six mètres
le cavalier en b 5
la dame en b 6 mais c'est peut-être pas
mieux
maintenu que ce monde est toujours sur
la broche brochet d' adam 2t match où il
a dû voir le x 6 tours ces deux il n'a
pas vu le tour 1 et revient en c4 latour
saumonée qui va venir en c1
peut-être il espère avoir un dame b 3
peut-être c'est son espoir est encore
six minutes 24 le tour c'est un dam des
trois peut être le coup en tout cas
c'est ce qu'annonce l'ordinateur aussi
je n'avais pas dans leur haine jeu avant
de le voir puisque c'était pas le coup
numéro pas top 3 et ouais l'idée c'est
que sur gamme prend si on prend tout
reprend on va pouvoir prendre à deux
pour prendre cavaliers prend tous ces
trois et on va pouvoir se chauffer à
venir gagner le pion à complexe magnus
qui réfléchit ce qui va jouer le tour
c'est un ou pas il est recroquevillé sur
sa première sur ces deux premières
rangées magnus il peut plus reculer sous
peine de se faire
acculés ils jouent tour 3 pour éviter
pour éviter l'arrivée de la dame en b3
il couvre les
agen c'est bien joué de la part de
magnus il défend bien le joueur
norvégien
il est tellement dur à battre cavale et
b5 pendant qui arrivait vite pour ces 3
ouais on sent la fébrilité dans les
mains de magnus
mais il tient pour le moment
il tient qui aimait cinq tours détroit
il a mis les barbelés ils à pk croquis
qui lui donne un coup de main
il a réussi à tout bloquer défend à 3 et
défense et 3 il défend ses deux il
défend siens il défend des quatre peu
plus trop bouger mais il a tout couvert
alors est ce que maintenant il va y
avoir un plan à la tour c 6 fou des
huîtres ou b 6 pour venir en remettre
une couche
c'est possible
les barbelés sont sortis je crois qu'il
a joué tour c'est si saint jean
christophe
en tout cas ça défend un côté magnus
dominée une nouvelle fois dans ce match
mais il défend fièrement
on a deux doigts d'une surcharge
si la tour recule la dame va avancer et
on mettra la tour en c4 il a joué tour
b2 défend tout mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il a plus de courant
j'ai l'impression qu'il va se retrouver
quasiment sans coup le fou qui parent
des huit sas avait été annoncé il va
arriver en b 6 il va falloir être très
solide en là pour pour tenir ça si on
vient en 2 3 avec le fouille à la casse
c3 qui va qui va être lâchée ce qu'il
veut jouer dame f1 va pas vraiment la
plus value du coup
plus difficile de jouer un coup ici pour
pour les noirs
c'est du rhin at il doit envoyer du
ventoux h5 g4 g5 et voir ce qui se passe
il va perdre des quatre noms mais ça
paraît difficile là on est vraiment à
quelques à quelques minutes peut-être
d'une énorme sensation dans cette coupe
du monde
jean-christophe duda qui n'a pas encore
perdu dans la compétition et qui est en
train de marcher sur magnus tf1 tient
tout à mesdames f1 souvient b6 et un
frérot la boutique magnus en difficulté
en sueur ils suent à grosses gouttes
là il ya vraiment une énorme sur côté
côté norvégien sur incomparable les
écailles sont en train de tomber
il faut qu'ils réussissent à défendre
encore un petit peu magnus il faut tout
donner en défense il faut tout donner là
il est il est malin il est mal
il doit pas savoir comment faire il va
peut-être faire d'un mets fins fouet 3
mais il sent qu'ils sont ils en train de
glisser dans le ravin
qu'est-ce qui tente soit retourné pour
qu'ils aient joué non avec toi pas
trouvé de solution j'ai passé un 10
tiens je pense un ordi ils trouvent des
ressources encore mais là je vois pas
comment il peut jouer ça allait
branchies qui sont hors de l'eau là
fu emporterait de l'oeuf ou mangent pas
comme un cavalier un géant quand même
bien mûres et la tour des 3
c'est vraiment complexe là il a joué g4
il fait ce qu'il doit faire il faut
qu'ils envoient le contre eux je fasse
on y avait plus de coups utile donc il
faut envoyer du g4 pour du g5
il va y avoir du fou b6 qui avale et
prend des quatre maintenant qui part
atteint 83 mais va faire flamber si ce
fou 3 essayé de tenir et essayer
d'envoyer 1
c'est sa meilleure chance à magnus de
toute façon il peut pas améliorer son sa
table défensif qu'en page et 5,2 sud
peut-être joué cinq de suite mais j'ai
cinq t'attaches 5
on fera peut-être g6 pour essayer
surtout pour acheter chaque arrêt les
prend il a joué fouet 3 alors
attendez-vous b6 fou 3 je pense je met
un petit refresh évidemment ça bug c'est
fou et 6 ou 3 c'est bien ce que je
pensais
cavaillé ces trois dames des dames est
fin et on défend et on défend côté
magnus qui avaient dit qu'ils arrivent
en c3 d'après ce que je vois
dans ma chambre dans ma chambre dans le
conte des trois il peut aussi à lancer
deux mais ces deux j'aime pas trop
dans mes fins
semble être une option après le cavaly
va venir en au 4 mai pour le monde perd
rien mais peut-être les normes vont
faire après dam des cinq tours c3 pour
s'infiltrer passé la tour devant et
revenir avec la dame en c4 on va essayer
de passer les tours devant la dame pour
pénétrer d'abord avec les tours et
ensuite avec la dame alors que le chat
assez exceptionnel après du débat après
le débat sur la relativité dans le tchat
il y à un deuxième débat doit-on
débattre de la relativité sur un chat
d'échec
ça sent ça sent le banat évidemment
c'est complexe 1 c'est complexe
le débat pour savoir si le débat était
légitime
peut-être vont-ils bientôt débattre de
savoir si débattre sur le fait qu'un
débat soit légitime est légitime sur un
chat ou pas on ne sait pas c'est un chat
les gens qui débattent qui ont envie de
débattre ils ont envie d'en découdre
comme magnus et duda
donc maintenant normalement il va y
avoir la dame qui va se décaler le
cavalier qui va se décaler les tours qui
vont pénétrer
c'est le plan et ses shows en plus 3,25
pour duda il ya une place au candidat
qui validerait un vraiment le travail et
les progrès du joueur polonais mais
avant ça il ya magnus qui se dressent
sur la route du joueur polonais et
l'enjeu est grand aussi pour magnus
carlsen champion du monde mais qui n'a
jamais été capable dans sa carrière de
gagner une coupe du monde ce qui peut
comme il décide de la jouer remettre sa
légitimité en cause peut-être complexe
en tout cas magnus s'est vraiment mis à
mal on croirait végéta contre freezer
complexe pour le moment allez ça va
partir avec du avec de la pénétration
colonne c'est la grave progresser
progresser
freezer aussi j'étais actionnaire super
saiyan complexe un jeu tour ces deux
veut empêcher la pénétration complexe
donc sur qui aura lieu 4 il veut et
changea il veut peut-être joué tour ses
5 ooo le marlou des andes
ce serait se serait gourmand ça pour
jouer des prend et cavaliers des quatre
rôles à la magnus qui s'accrochent aux
branches
quatre noms il a joué en france et 6 je
pensais qu'ils voulaient sacrifier la
caluche magnus est allé jouer du
cavalier des cuatro
non il a pris prix est remis la tour en
d1
quelle séance d' attaque défense les
amis comme un entraînement comme à la
parade la tour qui rentrent en d1 et
duda qui a joué du tour c4i sinon il
aurait pu décider de prendre aussi et de
rentrer avec la tour mais il a mis la
tour en c4 allez moi je mets une pièce
sur défense de magnus ici joueur
polonais qui n'est pas assez précis je
trouve d'un point est fait un tour ces
trois s'assembler finito je suis
d'accord avec toc race dans le tchat
mais la dame c4 j'ai l'impression qu'il
va donner des opportunités de défense
attention ne pas laisser un saumon
s'échapper on a déjà vu des ours se
faire avoir un le saumon qui semble être
dans les pattes et qui glisse et qui
retourne dans la rivière maintenant le
saumon mais lecavalier en d2 terrible il
va se faire forcer les changes et il va
essayer de blindés avec le roi
à duda qui est proche de la
correctionnelle maintenant correctionnel
correctionnel lui les fientes mémé nul
ici à mon avis serait lourde de
conséquences mentalement après avoir
autant dominé les voix de magnus semble
impénétrable savait qu'après chiarelli
prend des deux tours en d2 on se demande
maintenant comment il va rentrer sur les
cases noires magnus va-tout blindé avec
son mauvais fou même ses six salles et
il a encore un peu de colle on sait mais
il a un peu laissé échapper le saumon et
cahiers tard que les seconds sont pas et
cahiers peut-être mais il est en train
de le laisser échapper et lui glisse
entre les doigts ray il lui glisse entre
les doigts
terrible très gluant
là il va falloir la terminer cela il a
quand même encore le bon fou contre le
mauvais fou puisque c'est son choix lui
qui tape et la colonne ces salles
colonnes ouverte de l'échiquier il peut
avoir un plan mais bon celui-là je pense
qu'on réussit pas à le faire marcher
dans une finale de rentrer leur a versé
4 est normalement le roi blanc a
toujours le temps d'arriver en d3 pour
colmater
un minus encore dans le dur un magnus
encore dans le dur il n'est pas tirés
d'affaires la position est toujours
supérieure pour les noirs ça va être une
longue sur souffrance mais oh
au bout du bout du tunnel il ya la mer
pour le saumon il va essayer d'aller
nager dans l'eau salée des océans faut y
aller il faut y aller pour magnus
maintenant il faut jouer il faut se
décider
il est sous pression il a plus beaucoup
de temps il réfléchit réfléchit à quoi
ce qui peut faire un genre de c'est pas
moi dame de se laisser changer et tenir
la finale avec la torah de leurs en d3
et tout bloquer moi je commencerai
peut-être par wave 3 mais c'est
peut-être une grosse connerie la fed à
me2 en premier 1
il est malin et les marlous dames 2e
tour ces trois g5 à le marlou des andes
un en tout cas qui a vraiment été idiot
de ne pas échanger les dames il le
tenait entre ses petits doigts et
maintenant il va devoir subir une contre
attaque son bonnet tension
jean-christophe il ne faut jamais
laisser magnus avoir dû contre jeu il
envoyait la tour en c3 allez sa part
avec gesing comme à nant côté magnus
ça va partir avec g sync oh non il fait
tour à deux ça continue à jouer petit
bras là il n'en arrive pas il veut pas
envoyer veut pas se découvrir magnus il
veut pas la perdre ma force de ne pas
vouloir la perdre il va finir par la
perdre justement terrible cette phrase
en suivant chemtura de il défend encore
il veut envoyer le gesing co j'imagine
un dame c4 avec tam prend pions prend
peut être intéressant mais magnus espère
peut-être pouvoir courir avec le roi à
voir puisque sur f3 il y aura de suite
vous prendrez 4 c'est vrai qu'après dams
et 4 dames prend pions prend s'il est
noir réussissent à ramener le roi en d5
ce serait gamme
voilà ça se joue au mental ça se joue
dans la tête
est ce que dame c4 marche dames c4 dame
prend pions prend l'intuition ce serait
que le roi va y arriver parce que même
sur un roi est fort de rouaroua détroit
y aurait toujours tour des trois fours
en d4 qui tombe et c'est pas encore fait
ni d'un côté ni de l'autre
mesdames c4 est assez rassurant ça va
éviter tous les contres jeu à base de g5
on sent qu duda n'est plus si serein que
ça il est maintenant trop proche de la
victoire
et pourtant si loin complexe food et
huit souffrent des huit jours et jamais
ce coup ça va être un coup de turbines
ça encore et je
food et 8 alors une idée qui m'échappe
le geste inco qui part il était logique
j'ai l'impression qu'il à contresens
duda gesing koki par tempo et quelle est
l'idée des noirs oui mais bon il fait
food et 8 g sent qu'il n'a pas de suite
hein ça sent le coup de chiottes
ça sent le coup de chiottes quand même
si on prend puis on prend attention
attention il ya du damage cinq cantons
qui part avec g6 peut-être d'une tour en
une tour en h1 aleba news qui va tout
donner maintenant il produit son effort
à contre courant il tente de remonter
pour pondre ses oeufs
la dame qui vient c4 il va lui forcer
les changes des dames maintenant au
c'est terrible les dames qui vont se
faire échanger
or il est plus free n'est pas bien
magnus dams et 4 dames français 4 il va
reprendre du pillon et plus très loin on
n'est plus très loin la défaite
maintenant il réfléchit duda pèse le
pour et le contre
c'est vrai qu'il pourrait faire tourner
points et tour ces trois sépare
c'est parfait c'est pas fait peut-être
surpris on prend maintenant yariv 3
parce qu'il a plus de flou prend des 4
et oui le food et 8 un coup un coup de
chiottes aller magnus 33.4 il faut tout
donner
ils passeront encore b5 tour des 3 mai
allez il faut il faut monter à la volée
pas du tout le coup de leur dire on va
être 4 je vis dans mon délire a wife
troyat franges et 5 pardon terrible
merci maxime il a fait des think tanks
le contre jeu le tout pour le tout da
sous pression ils jouent une place au
candidat je vous le rappelle puis on
prend des saints qui veut tourné de
temps prend à 3 tours prend des 5 et
trouver du contre jeu manu stresser un
magnus et oui pourrait une nouvelle fois
ne pas gagner une compétition avec tous
les joueurs
est-ce que sans le privilège du champion
du monde il le serait encore c'est la
question qu'on peut se poser
ça fait trois ans qui n'a pas eu à
défendre son titre avec dans une
compétition avec we manque en réalité
les meilleurs pourrait se faire battre
par un outsider 17e mondial duda censé
être le niveau en dessous mais qui le
domine assez copieusement tour d2 il va
prendre à trois allez ça paraît une
petite série de coups non il a joué tour
des 3 ou autour des 3 c'est peut-être un
coup de chiottes ça ils avaient
peut-être tout reprend 1,3 d'abord et
tour des 3 après on c'est terrible c'est
arrive il a peut-être craquer jean
christophe prend le coup de chiottes
on comprend pourquoi il est dix septième
mondial par la turbine données prises
prises et tour des 3 après c'était quand
même simple hausse était simple quand
même c'est la même position sans le pion
à trois c'est
riboud c'est terrible le craquage
il a trop voulu assurer et maintenant
c'est égal le roi va revenir
et oui on comprend pourquoi jean
christophe n'est pas mieux classés il a
petit slip et au le tour points à 3
tours détroit était tellement évident et
le saumon qui s'échappe et qui va nager
en haute mer il doit être dégoûté
jean-christophe là mon avis c'est la fin
du match pour lui il n'y arrivera pas
magnus qui va tout défendre et qui va
peut-être même jouer le gain dans cette
finale il a gâché une munition quand
même jean christophe rault bon c'est pas
de chance en auto proclamé joueur
méritant de jouer les candidats à un
terrible terrible à umanis a bien
défendu il a mis sous pression
la marche était trop haute la marche
était trop haute
ce marche was too hot for deux
polonaises player complexe
plex
non très complexe tous vos textes
section ouest avec magnus après avoir
battu bas qui a quand même prouvé qui il
pouvait faire des belles choses mais
attention ce pas tout à fait fini ça
peut encore perdre d'un côté ou l'autre
je peux repris la paf et b5 avec les
noirs il peut complètement retourné et
horrible quand même ce qu'il a raté
jean-christophe c'est incroyable de pas
avoir fait tout refait à 3 puis tour des
c'était honnête non tellement facile
alors à temps
non parce qu'avec le bessin qui laisse
fawcett magnus sature bogaert peut-être
des deux côtés est ce que fout p63
détroit faut prendre trois rois prend
des quatre apprend roi prend roi ses 5,3
g saint croix b 6-3 5-3 bessette g53 c6
g4 b6 est lancée bouillant c'est hyper
chaud il ya plus le temps de calcul et
maxime qu'il réussisse ghani 6 rus 6-3
des 3b 6 3 et trois fois 5 3 des 4 sa
clique au hasard hein malheureusement on
a un peu du mal à suivre grâce à une
retransmission encore très qualitative a
un côté côtes américains réussissent ou
c1
et 6,3 c5 est ce qu'il n'est pas en
train de se faire retourner maintenant
duda attendait il a pas x 5 x 5 et 1 6 3
5 pouces et un fou ces trois 3 b 6 des
cas 3 bessette des trois rois à 6 des
deux bouffe bouffe b6 vous prend
bessette vous prend 1,5 sa gagne oh là
là le saumon en papillote croit le papy
hothead c'est complètement forcé c'est
terrible ils obligés de jouer b6 hockey
b6 ses shows et des cas 3 ck3 17
non mais ça va pas gagner la seconde f5
et u6 duda qui l'a ratée fouet trois os
est terrible c'est terrible la finale
est terrible parce que pions prend roi
prend c'est hyper complet que j'aie raté
quelques coups
après super endroit c63 des trois-rois
bessif f5
si on prend aussi si on prend et g6
terrible
c'était hyper complexe on va regarder à
la cam en grand les gars on va regarder
à la cam en grand parce qu'on peut plus
on peut plus faire autrement
le pion qui part aura trois leroy qui
monte 3,6 alors est ce qui la fout c'est
5 3 et 5 fu panda iii bouffe non il va
être zoug zinc ou pas de roi f sera dé
5,3 quatre rois des trois fous c1 il
faut prendre f4 non
vous en pensez quoi des cas 3 prend
flambée 6 faut être deux fous g3 fou
prend 1,4 à saumos ned sow monnet d'
ouais ça gagne aussi comme ça et c'est
terminé c'est terminé jean-christophe
duda élimine magnus carlsen de la coupe
du monde
papilles hothead hausse est terrible il
balance toutes les pièces toutes les
pièces qui sont balancés comme un gros
tas sur l'échiquier
mais magnus ne remporte pas une nouvelle
fois cette coupe du monde
il a trouvé plus fort que lui ouais
c'est terrible c'est terrible
c'est terrible papillaud ted
le tweak qui va partir
terrible j'en vois un petit tweet
le saumon fumé sa part
par le tweed qui par les amis le tout
était parti est en tout cas un immense
bravo à jean christophe qui élimine qui
élimine karl scène qui était favori de
la compétition mais qui une nouvelle
fois ne réussit pas à prouver qu'il est
qu'il est le meilleur
terrible et place place au candidat a
mérité un pur duda par le tweet est
magnifique quand même le tweet est quand
même magnifique
là j'ai envoyé un tweet très qualitatif
1 qui aurait parié sur une finale car à
kindu da sérieux pas moi
noda est vraiment vraiment incroyable en
maintenant le tout est beau le tweet evo
qui est le tweet de tweets qui peut
envoyer un débat
baky mvele en finale mais cette finale
est sympa aussi ouais c'est les deux
meilleurs joueurs sur toute la
compétition clairement qu'ils vont au
final y'a pas de ya pas de doute un
parce que là ça aurait été un semis hold
up
une victoire de magnus qui a quand même
été dominé sur le match un petit replays
des coûts de la fin mai pour voir ça
c'est un peu fini j'ai envie de dire à
la wesley so 1 avec une belle domination
finale et feydeau cia fouet l'autre
nouvelle c'est fedoseyev qui ne jouera
pas les candidats qui ne s'est pas
qualifiée aux candidats par la coupe du
monde
il n'aura pas le match de repêchage
entre guillemets terrible
jarry qui n'élimine et max duda sort le
saumon on a juste à dire bravo ouais
ouais le match pour la 3ème place ils
sont des deux joueurs est très
clairement très très clairement
kabel belle victoire de duda ça a été
jusqu'au bout ça aurait donné quoi des
3b 5-fu j'ai trois rois b6 fouet f4 ou
presque à trois points f4 apprend b
s'être apprend aux 5,3 cc3f 5,3 décès 3g
cinq recettes 35.7 g5 ou trois c4 foulée
trois rois c5 vous prend vous prend
prise rade et 6,3 g 5 3 7 3 5 3 et 7 5
roy g6 et b5
ce cas belle victoire 1-2 duda jeu
précis voudrait qu'on suive demain s
continue à suivre le ton à demain
honnêtement j'ai aucune idée puisque
pour moi les joueurs sont qualifiés et
le tournoi est plus ou moins fini sais
pas quel point vous avez envie de suivre
la fin je mets deux matches pour la
troisième place du coup a vraiment
aucune importance je met un petit vote
on va voir
regardez plutôt pour voir je ferai
peut-être un sondage s'est passé avec
chaises comme quoi je vais leur demander
la différence entre la n2 way c'est
vraiment pas d'argent pour eux
j'ai même forains que ouais pour la
finale c'est la même chose
quand on aime un peu deg ne pas voir la
fiche quartier à kincardine en finale
ben ouais mais enfin le meilleur a gagné
aujourd'hui quand même
l'aqim favoris mais attention du dal est
il devenu un autre joueur d'échecs tout
cas il a l'air d'avoir beaucoup
progressé après la chose qui peut être
un peu bizarre c'est qu'il peut y avoir
une une décompression en fait demain
parce que l'objectif est rempli en fait
donc c'est difficile de savoir quel
joueur va réussir à mieux se mobiliser
qu'un con
avec saint cloud la victoire demain way
duda aussi on peut pas savoir
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
duda ça va lui
ça va lui faire ça va lui faire du bien
pour la suite de sa carrière il sera
très dangereux en eau aux candidats très
clairement parce que là il semble
vraiment avoir progressé on se retrouve
un petit peu plus tard non allant
d'aidés qui m'a écrit qu'elle allait
faire le title donc retrouver un tout
petit peu plus tard les amis moi je vais
aller me faire une petite sieste
merci d'avoir suivi et on se retrouve
vers 18 heures et le title on va voir on
va voir si dd donne quelque chose on se
retrouvera du coup de main pour
poursuivre la compet a vu que le oui y'a
quand même largement gagné en tout cas
merci à vous tous d'avoir suivi
à bientôt à tout à l'heure en fait ciao
ciao reposez vous bien